Josh, Mareko, congratulations.
Both of you made signature
blades that have propelled you
into the third round
of competition,
giving you a chance at the
title of Forged in Fire champion
and another shot
at that $10,000.
Well now, we're going to send
you back to your home forges
to recreate an iconic
blade from history.
And that weapon is the Ida.
Awesome.
WIL WILLIS: The Ida
is a long cutting
sword most commonly used by the
Yoruba people of West Africa.
Their idolization of Ogun,
the god of metal and war,
led their blacksmiths
to be among the most
skilled in West Africa.
With its leaf-shaped blade, that
can be single or double edged,
the Ida was a practical tool for
both agriculture and hunting,
as well as a deadly
weapon on the battlefield.
In combat, it was often
laced with pepper or poison
to paralyze enemies and ensured
that the slash of the Ida
left many dead in its wake.
The length of the blade must
be between 22 and 26 inches.
Additionally, it must
have a double edge.
I've never heard of
this weapon before.
I mean, I've seen
weapons that are similar,
but I'm not really
a weapons expert.
So if I come away
with a win, it's
not going to be a cheap win.
I might make a great
blade and beat--
you know.
I did last time.
You will have five
days at your home
forge to complete
this challenge.
At the end of those
five days, you'll
return to present your finished
Idas to the panel of judges.
I'm really proud that
I've been able to make
it to the final round again.
I feel like I have what it
takes to win this competition,
and I also really
want to win for Doug.
WIL WILLIS: It's down to
just Doug and Jason's picks.
Don't let them down.
Good luck, bladesmiths.
We'll see you in five days.
JOSH SMITH: Good luck.
MAREKO MAUMASI: Let's do this.
JOSH SMITH: Today's day one.
I'm back home.
It's a couple below
zero this morning.
It's time to get to work.
I'm just going to stack up
a bill out of Damascus here.
This is going to
be my river going
down the center of the blade,
alternating layers of steel.
I'm going to be doing
a really complicated
Damascus blade
with a lot of welds
and a lot of chances for error.
I was on the show
last season, and I
was absolutely happy and
proud of the Kora sword
when I built it.
And I still am.
Just didn't win.
This is a bit of a shot
at redemption for me.
That thing's ready to twist.
I'm twisting this metal to
give it a really cool pattern
along the edge of this sword.
The twisting is a
very intense process,
and you're just really
watching that steel close,
making sure you're not
shearing it in half.
I'm going to call that good.
I don't want to push my luck.
MAREKO MAUMASI: Back
at my home forge.
The challenge is to
build an Ida sword.
My plan is to make kind of
a mosaic steel, which is
aesthetically really beautiful.
And into the forge and
the great white yonder.
I'm going to do a full integral
blade, which means the blade,
the guard, and the
full tang in the handle
are all going to be forged out
of the same piece of steel.
Biggest concern is that
the welds might not take.
So I'm just going to keep my
fingers crossed, keep my cool,
and just do things
the way I normally do.
And should come out just fine.
Like I'm forging in
fire or something.
See what I did there?
JOSH SMITH: It's day three.
My blade's grown.
I'm ready to heat treat.
I'm feeling pretty anxious.
Two days of work
comes down to this.
You just never know what's
going to happen when
you actually go into that oil.
Here goes nothing.
OK.
Baby looks as
straight as an arrow.
This test piece that I
heat-treated with my sword,
I'm going to beat up a
little antler with it
and see how it does.
That one took a chunk out there.
I ended up with two chunks
in the end that were missing,
but I don't feel like I have
time to play with right now.
But I think I'll be fine.
MAREKO MAUMASI: It's
pretty damn cold in here,
so I use my little hobo
fire, an old turkey fryer.
What's most important is getting
good heat treat on the blade.
So I just need to bring it up
all to an even temperature,
pull it out, and
give her a quench.
All right, that
should be plenty.
Still looks pretty
dang straight.
Woo-hoo!
I actually feel a little
bit ahead of where I thought
I was going to be today.
My integral guard
area is in there.
I got my full tang.
So the rest of it pretty much
from this point on is grinding.
JOSH SMITH: It's time
to start a handle.
The handle's what cost me
the competition last year.
I'm going to choose
this African Blackwood.
This sword is from West Africa.
So I'm trying to keep
it somewhat authentic.
I fight this battle between
staying historically correct
and making something that
the judges can hang on to.
It's looking good.
I want the look to
be a bit of my own.
Sword blade is real Ida,
and the handle is real Josh.
What the-- [bleep]?
There's a hole in the wood.
The frickin'-- there's
a hole in the wood.
Right in the middle
of the block.
Usually when you see a little
pinhole like that pop up
and you keep grinding, it
just gets bigger and bigger,
and you've ruined the handle.
I actually think I might be
able to file through it tomorrow
if I have time.
Today was a pretty wearing
day, but in the end,
I've got a sword
with a handle on it.
I'm pretty comfortable
with where I'm at.
MAREKO MAUMASI: We're
in the home stretch.
I just have some
light finish work
to touch back up on the
blade before I etch it,
and then reattach the handle,
and then sharpen the thing.
Feels like it's got a
little bit of a tippy edge.
It'll definitely cut.
I feel really good about what
I was able to accomplish.
Question is whether or not
it's actually going to survive.
There's only one
way to find out.
And that's to let
Doug play with it.
DOUG MARCAIDA: This
is a kill test.
To see how lethal your weapons
are, I will take your weapons
and deliver multiple
slashes and hacks
on these ballistic dummies.
Josh, you're up first.
Are you ready?
JOSH SMITH: I'm ready.
DOUG MARCAIDA: Let's do this.
JOSH SMITH: All right.
Those ballistics dummies
are pretty tough.
They're a hard
thing to lacerate.
So this test makes me
a little bit nervous.
[electric guitar music]
DOUG MARCAIDA: OK, Josh.
This is a wicked blade.
On the initial hack
right here, the blade
went all the way through into
the ribs and broke those ribs.
The other side, same thing.
That would disembowel
this dummy.
Your weapon will kill.
JOSH SMITH: Thank you.
DOUG MARCAIDA: Good job.
JOSH SMITH: Thank you very much.
DOUG MARCAIDA:
Mareko, you're next.
You ready?
MAREKO MAUMASI: I'm ready.
DOUG MARCAIDA: Let's do this.
MAREKO MAUMASI: All right.
I don't know how well
my weapon's actually
going to perform because it
has kind of a beefier edge
geometry, which
doesn't necessarily
lend it to slicing very well.
[electric guitar music]
DOUG MARCAIDA: Well,
Mareko, it is sharp.
As you can see what it did, it
lacerated right in all the way
to the chest cavity, breaking
the ribs that are in there.
On the horizontal
slashes, same thing.
It lacerated deep.
Feels good, balances out,
and your blade will kill.
Good job.
MAREKO MAUMASI: Thank you.
DOUG MARCAIDA: Next up
is the sharpness test.
To test your double edged
sword, I will take your weapon
and deliver three slashes per
blade across this web of ropes.
If your Ida is sharp, it
should meet no resistance.
Josh, you're up first.
Are you ready?
JOSH SMITH: Let's do it.
DOUG MARCAIDA: Let's do this.
[electric guitar music]
I'll tell you, Josh,
this is definitely sharp.
It met no resistance
cutting through the ropes.
It feels good in the hand.
Your sword, sir, will cut.
Good job.
JOSH SMITH: Thank you very much.
Appreciate it.
DOUG MARCAIDA: All
right, Mareko, you ready?
MAREKO MAUMASI: Bring it on.
DOUG MARCAIDA: Let's do this.
[electric guitar music]
Well, Mareko, your
blade is fast.
It's light.
It did lacerate through
some of the ropes,
and some of them it didn't.
Overall though,
your blade will cut.
MAREKO MAUMASI: Thanks, Doug.
DOUG MARCAIDA: Next up
is the strength test.
Dave?
DAVID BAKER: Gentlemen, to test
the strength and durability
of your blades, I'm going to
chop into these femur bones
three times.
Now, the point of
this test is not
to see how many
bones I can break,
but to see how well
your blades hold
up through that punishment.
Josh, you're up.
Are you ready?
JOSH SMITH: I'm ready.
DAVID BAKER: All right.
[electric guitar music]
JOSH SMITH: Damn.
DAVID BAKER: Everything
stayed straight.
Everything stayed tight.
But you can see we've got some
extreme chipping on that blade.
Did sizable damage to
what we were swinging at,
but you can just
see those chips.
All right, Mareko, you ready?
MAREKO MAUMASI: [laughs] Yeah.
DAVID BAKER: All right.
MAREKO MAUMASI: I did my best
to make the geometry so it could
withstand this kind of use.
But seeing the damage that
happened to Josh's sword
makes my heart, like,
sink down in my stomach.
[electric guitar music]
DAVID BAKER: Well, Mareko, you
did pick up that slight bend,
but your edges are beautiful.
They've held up quite nicely.
Nicely done.
MAREKO MAUMASI: Thanks.
WIL WILLIS: Josh, Mareko,
it was definitely a battle.
But there can only
be one champion.
The Judges' Pick Forged in
Fire champion is Mareko.
Congratulations.
You are the Forged
in Fire champion.
Good job.
MAREKO MAUMASI: Wow.
JOSH SMITH: Congratulations.
[interposing voices]
WIL WILLIS: Josh, please
surrender your weapon.
JOSH SMITH: I feel they
made the right decision.
I may not be the Forged
in Fire champion,
but I'm still a great
bladesmith and a better dad.
But I showed my kids that you
step up and you do it again,
and you give it your best.
And I think I did that, and
I brought a beautiful sword.
Looks nice, but looks don't cut.
WIL WILLIS: Mareko, how does
it feel rising to the top,
earning a check for $10,000,
and being the Judges'
Pick Forged in Fire champion?
MAREKO MAUMASI:
Yeah, it's definitely
been a serious challenge.
But to be able to represent for
Doug, a man who I respect very
much, and to make it
to the end and win,
that makes me really proud.
I came so close to
winning last time.
It feels really good that
I was actually able to pull
off the win this time.
Winning the $10,000, it's
going to be so helpful
for myself and my family.
Doug, your horse won the race.
I hope that I made you proud.
So thanks for
bringing me back, man.
[electric guitar music]